rick
is um both a local and a national
treasure
uh as he uh is someone who um
really brings perspective to media that
might be forgotten
uh films images uh
sounds and now really uh history
a local history but also uh of national
importance
uh as so often can happen in the bay
area um
so um i'll bring him right up here but i
just want to mention
so he doesn't have to that uh one of his
other projects the prelinger library
prelingerlibrary.org they are a private
library open to the public
all of you should go they're working to
double their hours
and to make it go from being you know
funded by them themselves to being also
community funded so
take a look at the fundraiser that
they're doing go to prelingerlibrary.org
for that information and uh big round of
applause now for rick pellinger
um michael thank you for that generous
and unsolicited announcement
um thanks to the bar for the cappuccino
which arrived just in time
and um thank you all for coming so this
is a little bit of a
uh something different have any of you
seen the earlier
incarnation of this talk macro city okay
so there's a little bit of you
two of you know what you're getting into
um this is something i've been
interested in and working on for a long
time but it may not quite be what you
expect
so i'm interested in the history of
communications infrastructure
especially infrastructure that's not um
visible to the unstudied eye and you
know the kind of infrastructure that you
can't easily see
goes back a long way you might even go
as far as uh
might even say as far back as latitude
and longitude but for most of us
when we think of infrastructure we think
of of stone of
concrete of iron bridges railroads
aqueducts pipelines roads piers massive
stuff and you know while um
communications themselves
are often invisible and typically fairly
weightless they're enabled by physical
networks that take up a lot of space and
also absorb a lot of investment they
possess
materiality the majesty of materiality
and also sometimes the inconvenience
of materiality so today i'm going to
talk about the history of communications
infrastructure
mostly in san francisco to a certain
extent in the bay area both the hardware
and a little bit about the kind of
messages that they've transmitted over
many years
and i'm going to especially focus this
talk could be
a day and it's already stretching it's
ballooning
and you'll see there's some things i'm
conspicuously
ignoring and of course you can bring
that up and q
a and shame me but i'm going to focus on
telephones and radio and some other
kinds of communication that wind
in and out of the chronology um
what i think rather than a complete map
really this is a visual and somewhat
audible
run through of some of the history and
try to extrapolate outward
to some questions that we might ask
about infrastructure
and about communications um and hope to
get a conversation going
so how would we communicate in the days
before
telephones we could write letters we
could call
um a messenger the archetypal telegraph
boy perhaps from the american district
telegraph
a mythical figure in 19th century
literature and culture
telegraph lines first connected san
francisco with san jose
and with stockton sacramento the
interior and marysville
starting in 1853 and that same year a
wire was extended from point lobos
over the dunes to telegraph hill and to
the merchants exchange so that news of
incoming ships
could arrive downtown instantaneously
and then to la
in in 1859 and the reason was so that
san francisco newspapers
could get news that came in on the
stages
into los angeles and then briefly news
from the pony express to carson city
and then to sf via telegraph in 1861
transcon telegraph and so 1877 we first
get telephone service in san francisco
this is a tumultuous year in american
history
unemployment drought strikes
violent strikes and anti-chinese
violence
strikes nationwide and there's a funny
correlation between
often times between social and economic
unrest
and the deployment of communication
systems and you can see why the phone
was attractive to
captains of industry because it could
pass on information instantaneously
without mediation without anybody else
in between except maybe an
operator but at the beginning you
couldn't get the operator directly
if you wanted to call somebody you first
had to signal your telegraph
office which happened to be in the same
room as the switchboard
and they would tap your call out on the
tape and then the telegraph
operator would pass the tape to a
switchboard operator
who would connect your line to the line
you wanted kind of like
booking a session on the internet in
advance
and until 19 until 1880 the operators
were teenage boys
but their language was considered
unseemly they'd say things like hello
hello what do you want
are you through well why don't you hang
up this you know
and so they they phased out the boys um
1887
this is house top wiring we're a little
a little bit bright here but most of the
downtown roofs
in san francisco had frames supporting
telephone telegraph
and messenger wires and in residential
neighborhoods they just nailed boards to
the roof
and projected them out from the
buildings and wires were out in the open
to allow for inspection this was not
very resilient as you could
imagine and rooftop wiring people would
hang laundry up on it
or if people went up on the roof they
would trip over the wires and the phones
would go out
and so the telephone pole was introduced
in the 1880s
gradually replacing the more informal um
structures but you know san francisco
was dusty
and wet dust that was dust plus
fog blew into wires and shorted them out
and usually by noon that evaporated but
it was often hard to make calls in the
morning
and and so they figured out how to
insulate cables it's really kind of
interesting this sort of nature
physical interaction in 1886 they build
the branch exchanges in the city and we
get underground cables
in 1892 downtown which is why in the
famous market street film that you've
probably all seen a million times
you don't see telephone wiring it's
already underground
and there's constant constant innovation
a lot of reinvestment
in the 1880s all the edison manufactured
phones are replaced by
bell telephones and then the long
distance telephone set
the set that is interoperable with a
network
that um amplifies is is introduced
so by the 1890s a lot of businesses have
telephones in san francisco but the
general public
sees them as frivolous and expensive um
kind of like the way cell phones were
before about
1990 um pactell
introduced four party lines and ten
party lines in 1894 they were much
cheaper
and a few more residences subscribed and
in 1896 they came up with kind of the
killer
innovation which was called the kitchen
telephone which only cost
50 cents a month and you could call out
to order food
and other supplies for the house but the
phone had no bells and so you couldn't
call into it it was outgoing
calls only a little bit like the one-way
internet
and plus there were 20 other phones on
your lines was frequently busy
and the idea was to to groom customers
you know to get them to
to buy one-way service and then want
two-way
and that kind of worked so the quake and
fire
on you know six pretty much destroyed oh
you really can't see this that's too bad
but here's one of the very early
temporary
telephone directories from april 28 and
it's kind of interesting within
10 days they had temporary wires strong
to link the key the key especially the
emergency
operations this is from october
1906 i love how engine 11 at 15th avenue
south which is
later became an alphabetical street in
the bay view section is butcher town 18
you know there was a butcher town
phone exchange um but by 1907 they've
it's normal and as a result um you know
downtown was mostly destroyed a lot of
people relocated to the
western edition into the mission and
about a hundred thousand people left
sixty six thousand moved out to where
land was cheaper
and as a result the telephone couldn't
really follow it was hard to um
build out as quickly as people were
moving
and then the phone becomes national it's
tremendously
expensive to call long distance but it
becomes possible this is
1895. this is one of the prizes in our
library
the national telephone directory these
were issued until 1911
and it's this incredible directory of
sort of the ruling circles
of the country and in fact in the dc
page if you look sort of in the middle
you see
alexander graham bell is listed you
could call him at washington 32.
that's pretty cool um this book goes
from maine to st
louis and beyond st louis you couldn't
you couldn't call nationally anymore
before the 1890s we had the chinese
telephone exchange at 742
washington um this you've there's a lot
of
mystique that's grown up around it these
women
pretty much worked for memory people did
have numbers in the china exchange but
basically within that exchange
everything was handled manually and they
remembered the subscribers
some of you may have seen the the
chinese ideographic telephone books that
were published
at least through the late 40s they often
show up on ebay
um there was also and nobody really
knows much about this but there's the
pekin exchange in downtown oakland
as well a very small localized um
exchange how about um the telephone is a
broadcast medium this is kind of like
a t and comcast you know going into the
the programming business in 1913 about
10 companies called the telephone herald
started up in the u.s the oakland
company seems to have been an epic fail
it did a demo in capwell's downtown and
it doesn't ever seem to have built out
but you know this worked in 1881 in
paris
there was a telephone broadcast system
that used double lines for stereophonic
sound um in budapest the system started
up in 1893
and actually ran until 1944.
it was a an alternate really to the
radio system of course you really
you'd sometimes you'd have a special set
with a speaker but typically you sat
with something up against your ear
i mean this may seem laughable um but i
think that what's interesting about it
is that um
there was a realization that that copper
network once you'd
set up a telephone infrastructure that
you could repurpose it that you could do
something
else with it you know think uh think
dial-up
so um this is our 100th
anniversary of the ppie and the year
before
in may 1914 they put on something called
the ball of all nations
and this is just wonderful i wish that
we'd reenacted this as part of the
anniversary
they built a hidden wire network under
the floor
and it was connected with copper nails
that were set close apart
facing um up to the top of the the
surface of the floor
and the spouse of the telephone employee
works shoes with copper soles
and and then wires ran up through her
clothing just like me
um to a telephone set and then she would
invite people to dance
and she would ask her dancing partners
who would you like to talk with and then
a switchboard operator in the background
listened in on everything that was said
and whenever she heard a name she rushed
through a call on special lines
so i mean you know wow um
july 1914 the first
transcontinental phone call and this was
you couldn't drive across country
without a lot of hassle but they did um
they they got the lines finished in 1914
and they celebrated
january 25 1915 bell
said in new york mr watson come here i
want you
mr watson sitting in san francisco said
it'll take me five days
and the call took 23 minutes to connect
um 1915 also the first transmission of
speech
across the atlantic by radio telephone
this was commercialized from new york to
london and later
sf to london in 1927 i think it was
65 for the first three minutes and
multiply by
i don't know 14 or something just
insanely expensive
this ad is kind of interesting um
basically it says that the telephone
best serves those who have become
one with us in speech that you have to
speak the same language to talk on the
phone and of course this is obvious in a
way although now we wouldn't
now att of course advertises its 140
language interpreted
system but you know there's an
interesting connection with the nativism
of the period um this ad is from 1920
more transcontinental routes open 1923
1927
by the late 20s early 30s i don't know
exactly when there's four
routes they're redundant they can root
if um
the sierra nevada is out with the snow
falls
you know over over the past you can
route from salt lake city to la and then
back
up long distance rates
from 1922
multiplied by about 14. so a daytime
call from san francisco to new york
1650 for the first three minutes
multiplied by 14.
this was not uh you know this was like
like richard branson's you know galactic
virgin galactic um late 1920s to 1930s
we see customer dialing you know this
was a huge
educational issue um but it obviously
saved the phone company a tremendous
amount in labor
and it's a step forward in customer
powered
infrastructure and in a lot of ways you
know um
i'm attracted to the contrarian idea
that the telephone was maybe a more
quote unquote revolutionary invention in
the internet
may have been simply because it was the
first time
especially with the direct dialing that
there was unmediated communication
between from individual to individual
and that's just
a tremendous change in its time
systemically it may not have been as
strong a change the internet but i think
it it's historically perhaps some
under underrated oh
i'll go see over there you finished your
coffee john i'll answer it
it's probably the mailman
[Music]
john it's from sally
she says the baby has the measles oh
dear
well now measles that's not so serious
all kids get them sooner or later john
warren
you know ruthie is only 14 months old
poor little deer
i'm worried well if you're worried why
don't you call her up
you've got her number in that little
book of yours
it's just about eight o'clock in san
francisco they'll be up
you know i believe i will go ahead
call her you'll feel better
[Music]
[Applause]
three one eight
g a five
two three six
eight are you sure it isn't too early
out there oh no it's it's eleven o'clock
here that means it's eight o'clock out
there
hello sally sally this is mother
simple wasn't it she just picked up her
telephone and dialed her daughter in san
francisco california
in a matter of seconds she is talking
with her
simple and yet you are seeing the
results of many many years of
coordinated effort
in research engineering and operating
experience
back when we were area code 318
[Applause]
i i'm surprised that more people haven't
studied these exchange maps the
expansion is actually quite interesting
um and that's a little much for us but
for now we can remember the wonderful
names you know atwater
douglas xbook jordan klondyke
etc bay view skyline
and then this is how
operators completed long distance calls
using this keyboard i'm about to show
you
and here are the tones and remember
these tones they're called
multi-frequency signaling
remember how you would hear that when
you'd make a call and you'd hear that
this is the keyboard
i'm actually from an oregon switchboard
and this is what the
um what the operator would use we're
going to come back to that
there's treasures and phone books these
are the old address phone books
and this is a picture of 24th street in
san francisco in
what would that be 1956 and it's an
incredible way of thinking about
how neighborhoods have changed this is a
lot of people
come to us in the library to see those
interesting also to see even in
relatively prosperous
times how unevenly telephone service was
distributed
in san francisco so another kind of
telephone is um
is our fire alarm box system this
actually goes back to 1865
and the terminal point for fire alarms
was opened in 1915 next to 1011 at 10 11
turk currently the department of
emergency management building
and this was kind of a primitive
telegraph system and i won't go into
details but if somebody
pulled a box at 25th and connecticut the
digits 2615
would be marked on a moving paper tape
and then from there
uh this would tap out in fire stations
all around the city and then engines
would um
respond that one the thing about the
alarm boxes that are really interesting
is that they're just insanely
resilient there's still 2040 fireboxes
on the streets
and they continue to function throughout
loma prieta
they're maintained i think mostly by one
man still
and it's it's a neat system eighty
percent of the calls are false alarms
twenty percent are legit but it's um
inherently hardened against disaster and
it does save lives
we also have the mayor's emergency
telephone system
uh red phones which um is independent of
the telephone companies it's designed to
operate during power failures it's a
hundred years old
there's 460 of these boxes and i think
each rookie cop still gets a key to them
and these phones are in the mayor's
house and the supervisor's house and in
fire stations around the city and if we
run into a situation where we lose power
and we lose radio systems and we lose
the internet this plus radio hams is
is what's going to coordinate um
emergency response and disaster relief
in
san francisco so when you see one of
these they're not just
antiques um mobile phones which we of
course take for granted
the first were in the 40s but there were
only a few channels this is what one of
them looked like
in every city everything was arranged
through the operator and you had to push
to talk
at the very beginning right half duplex
you couldn't speak and listen
at the same time it gets better in 1965
but the limits in the system
still meet only a few hundred people and
then we start to see the cell plan and i
think you kind of basically
know about this the whole idea is that
you divided territorial into little
cells
with localized transmitters and you hand
off as
as people or vehicles move and so you
can reuse
frequencies and it uses a lot of um
of computer power and there's a lot of
bandwidth to backhaul the signal back
from the
remote sites to the um to the switching
stations but it's still
super efficient and of course it took
the world by storm
1983 these beautiful dine attacks
there's one on ebay here for
525 buy it now um
the phones that we use now are just
about all gsm
1990s text messages we first see in the
country in
1993 cell phone roaming was terrible
they used to put out these books
instructions if you went to san
francisco how to dial into the system
and how to arrange your billing and
these coverage maps which
are to say the least visionary
lots of education was required this is
from the
late 80s early 90s
kind of funny and then cell phone
etiquette 2001 this is an in
pack bell wireless put this out about
attitudes and behavior americans would
rather visit the dentist
than sit next to somebody in the movies
talking on the phone
um just a little uh apropos nothing if
you visit lawrence livermore lab you've
got to lock your phone up in these
little
self storages outside the security
perimeter
paging you know people joke about paging
now but it is an
incredibly efficient system for multi
multi-casting messages it's used now in
the
by public safety people a little bit
still in business
in the year 2000 there were nine major
paging companies in san francisco
um it's it's it's worth investigating
so every organizational system breeds
its own kind of deconstruction
breeds its own kind of transgression
this is early phone freaking
playing with the infrastructure remember
the operators multi-frequency keyboard
this is a blue box that allows
you to mimic those tones yourself to
seize a line
by hitting the clear key up in the upper
right
and then you can pretty much own the
system
this was my blue box that i bought in
1972 from wozniak and jobs in berkeley
and who came around the dorms to sell
them
and we had a wild demo evening as we
called around the world
and steve jobs called dr
arthur jonov who wrote the primal scream
because he was obsessed with
him and his daughter and you know and
wised off
operators in the british uh telephone
system and so on it was it was my first
direct contact at being in touch with
a network that simulated a kind of life
and i wish i tried to find this was
recorded but
the man that recorded it his
two-year-old re-recorded the tape anyway
it's now at the
computer history museum there it is
um and then another kind of phone
freaking
in um there's a lot of talk these days
about what's wrong with the younger
generation
so here's an item on the credit side a
group of five teenagers who have
organized their own telephone company
put it together from surplus and junk
equipment
into a smoothly functioning network that
serves 28 subscribers
[Music]
they string wires and install phones
themselves too
so far the service is free the young
businessman engineers behind it all have
put up the little
cash they needed and the still growing
system already has two exchanges in
kensington and el cerrito
think of those lucky homes with a
private wire to handle those
marathon teenage phone calls there's
community service
for you
[Music]
i i think it's great we should do this
in san francisco
um so radio is as old as the universe it
passes through um
everything including our bodies we're
still hearing cosmic radio noise from
the big bang
and um added to what used to be this
ambient presence of the natural world we
now have a
chaotic collection of human produced
vectors
every built up area is blanketed by
emissions from
powerful broadcast transmitters this is
mount wilson this is not
san francisco extremely high power
transmitters
lower power stations are usually
building mounted
am and shortwave broadcasters like kgo
use towers that are sited in areas of
high ground
conductivity such as wetlands this is a
beautiful building near the dumbarton
bridge
and then there's this bewildering fabric
of low power transmissions from the
wi-fi chips and the cellular radios we
all carry around to the
rfid tags on library books and passports
and
pallets in costco those are typically
passive
rather than they don't transmit out but
they are pulled
by transmitters family radios portable
public safety radios
radio hands with morse code and then
voice and then music and then in 1909
somewhat disputed but we would hear the
first
um voice broadcast radio transmissions
from san jose
which later would evolve into kcbs which
um
traces its history back to 1909
broadcasting pioneers in the 20s this is
a tiny narrow slice of the spectrum
and it's chaotic it's not well regulated
until 1927. all sorts of people and
businesses go on the air
at the initially mostly on the same
channel
and it's it's it's chaos it gets cleaned
up by 1935
broadcast radio is much better
coordinated uh
the point here is that these clear
channels like if you look at 830
koa or if you look at 700 wlw these are
clear channel stations that could be
heard
all over the country am was really a
national
medium to a great extent it becomes
mainstream
people rely on radio to fulfill a vast
spectrum of needs and desires
in the same way that they would later
rely on tv
and as far as tv is concerned philo t
farnsworth
at 202 green street our um transgressive
pioneer who
tried to shove it to rca for many many
years
sent a single straight line from one
room to another
in his lab next year he demos
his straight line for his backers who
are anxious to see some
money coming back in so he transmits a
dollar sign
and in 1929 he sends pictures of people
including a three and a half inch image
of his wife whose eyes are closed
because the lights are so blinding
so it's great to think of these weak
signals that barely radiated past a room
as a historically significant peak on
the
historical spectrum graph and by the
1930s we have a really sophisticated
wireless infrastructure in the bay area
and like the bay area the wireless the
spectrum
becomes militarized in the 40s there's
naval transmitters everywhere alameda
skaggs island
up in the delta there's a vast amount of
traffic passing through
this is in 1948 this is called homograph
which is a
local radio guide for the bay area and
what's so cool about it
is it takes an integrated view so here's
your mainstream am
and there's your early fm your shortwave
and they even list the police
frequencies you know the
it's this whole idea that of um uh
of looking at radio holistically
103. are you calling headquarters
yeah i got a 418 the 400 block of
broadway street
[Applause]
400 broadway three out of ones we have
before 18 a unit to 10 25 400 broadway
three out of four two blocks away
out of force two blocks away
[Applause]
you know you're all clearing each other
out of four did you say you were 97 on
broadway fourth at the mig
garden global high gardener
three out of four go forward to fish and
help
we have a code four submission held by
three atom point four hundred broadway
code forces vision hell benny again it's
not there
10 22. so this is what police radio used
to sound like this is july 26
1979 and there's trouble at the mobu
high gardens
on 440 broadway um this is an
old school system it will skip i've
heard it in connecticut
it's still it's still there in case our
um
fancy trunk radio system breaks down
it's got kind of a pure
sound to it we'll come back to this in a
little bit i'm just a word and i'm not
really doing broadcast
as i should but here's the tv picture in
1957
one courageous uhf station k-san tv
didn't last um the region
we didn't get tv until after world war
ii but it built out fairly quickly this
is uh
there are people in this room who could
talk much more authoritatively about the
history of
television infrastructure than than i
can but i'm really interested in useful
radio um and in 1964 we have this
you know american cities begin to be un
racked by
civil unrest call it what you like and
money begins to flow from the feds to
the locals to
fund riot control equipment to modernize
communication systems
and so manufacturers perfect this
handheld walkie-talkie
so that every cop can have his own radio
even in 1973
in the first year of streets of san
francisco
there aren't many radios and even they
have the kind you have to stretch out
the
telescoping antenna you know this took a
while
but um the old-time two radio system
two-way radio systems
are replaced by fancier radio systems
and the existence of communications
triggers an interest in intercepting
them and so radio shack mass
markets these patrolmen radios you can
listen to the cops
and then uh in a in a few years even
more sophisticated
radios like scanners are introduced in
the 1970s we begin to see the
proliferation of microwave dishes
around the city and there's some
environmental concern the famous
book was the zapping of america by paul
brodeur
first serialized in the new yorker and
there were some studies san francisco
was an early
test bed for studies on non-ionizing
radiation
and this is for some people still a very
controversial issue a lot of people are
are
unhappy and and and feel sickened by
living close to sell
base stations some people are um feel
sickened by their wi-fi and there's a
lot of people that are concerned about
smart meters the science doesn't seem to
be very
conclusive at this point
but ultimately you know we carry devices
on our bodies and fewer and fewer people
really worry about it
um interesting how antennas begin to
retreat into the background of the urban
landscape we no longer
see them this is a fire in south of
market and the tv stations have um
raised their uh their microwave dishes
to point to sutro
but um this is one sort of rare moment
where
where aside from mount sutro where the
antennas are conspicuous 1973 we have
the co-location of many tv
and fm stations at sutro
uh we could do again there's people here
who know
uh much more about sutro than i do it's
it's
it's technologically and increasingly
aesthetically
uh a fascinating fascinating structure
there's also san bruno mountain very
interesting place to hike
um but let me go back a little bit to
this notion of surveillance
and counter surveillance be advised that
we got a phone call
the people we're interested in uh have
capability to monitor and
utilize scanners so be circumspect on
giving directions getting where you're
going there okay
yeah okay i won't say where that came
from but um
by the late 1970s and early 80s it's the
heyday of radio monitoring of
signal intelligence and traffic analysis
do people know what traffic analysis is
so if you have
radio signals or you have internet
traffic you have
messages being passed and you can't
necessarily
pick up what those messages are saying
maybe they're encrypted maybe they're
scrambled whatever maybe they're
obscure traffic analysis is looking at
the metadata how many
sources what direction are they coming
from
um what what do you know about the
characteristics of the signal
that help you understand valuable
information even if you don't know what
the message is
so that is um in situ surveillance of
suspected spies
under foreign diplomatic cover in the
late 1970s this is the fbi
in pacific heights probably looking at
the soviets near the consulate we
wouldn't hear this now
now it would be completely encrypted we
would hear static
you know just white noise or we wouldn't
hear anything at all
and this is a perfect example of a
signal which is essential you're just
hearing these
these alphabetic coordinates that
probably respond to some kind of a map
but the traffic analysis can still tell
you a great
thing about that so this becomes
pervasive for sensitive communications
and in 1986 a law called akpa electronic
communications privacy
is passed it's illegal to listen to cell
phones it's illegal to
decode or decrypt digital transmissions
and that law stands today here is one of
the more interesting buildings in san
francisco this is the department of
emergency management at
10 11 turk where i was um graciously
given
a tour of this very morning so these
slides are very very fresh
they haven't faded yet this is the
public safety dispatch and i was asked
not to
you know um show people's faces there
because
people are conscious of their privacy
but there's a console for each
um this is the police area which is
closest to the supervisors
in case they need coordination but a8 is
the
richmond district handheld a7 as well
they call it that but a7 is um main
dispatch for uh
for um gosh richmond paraval
and uh where's my brain anyway the west
side of the city
so these are incredibly sophisticated
consoles and this is what
somebody sees a 911 call taker and then
a radio dispatcher this is bogus you see
it's made out to fred flintstone
it's a training screen because we can't
reveal any um
private information but this was done
this morning and so all of this is typed
in
and this rather sophisticated um system
which is called a cad computer assisted
dispatch keeps track of status and
assigns case numbers and
so on it's really really interesting but
this is part of the background
um they also see maps and they see
certain sensitive locations
are marked here so this is a
a customized view
gis view for public safety dispatchers
and they also do triage if you make a
medical call
and you complain that you think there's
a stroke these are questions that are
asked
and then ultimately um something is put
together
for dispatch so that the the first
responders will know
what to do unlike some cities in san
francisco medical dispatchers are not
paramedics they're civilians
but this is a medically developed
system that helps to triage ahead of
time
we have a really complicated system
inside a trunk system in san francisco
it's getting old
it's analog it's no longer going to be
supported and so by
2018 there's a hope that they'll have a
fancy new
digital system put in um these are all
the police
channels that are used so we don't use
what's interesting is it's a software
thing now in the old days
fire used to have a channel police in
the north side had one channel police
and it's not done that way now it's all
done in
software and so talk groups which are
sort of virtual paths that are shared
are are set aside um i won't go into
this is analysis of
of who's busiest it's really fascinating
it turns out the library is one of the
busiest the library channel it's one of
the busiest on the san francisco system
this is um what they're expecting i
think i don't want to take the time
interoperability is a really big
issue you'll see it in the newspapers
even it's made its way into the public
press
because after 9 11 it was the fire
and the police didn't talk to one
another and this is one of the reasons
it has said why so many firefighters
died in the collapse of the world trade
center
my contention is that interoperability
is not a technical problem it's not
going to be solved by
throwing billions and billions of
dollars of expensive
technology at the problem it's a
cultural problem
uh typically people in different
departments don't like to share
information and this has
been a perennial problem and so we need
to think about how that's all going to
work it's a real i think
cultural issue um so 1990's the
beginning of massive data traffic it
begins as a trickle this is from 2000
and this is palm net did any of you have
palm pilots
further you for your expanded plan you
got 150 kilobytes
which was 90 messages a month we should
all restrict ourselves to 90 messages a
month and make them matter
um the question that this begs is can we
build
um sufficient infrastructure to support
the heavy bandwidth that people are
jumping to use
um especially when a lot of people don't
want to live next to the transmitters
that they're using
but it's a really interesting question
you know a lot of people think spectrum
is scarce spectrum is sold for huge
amounts of money
um but there's argument that of course
spectrum if it was assigned
on the fly and it was used in a much
more it was assigned
virtually that that scarcity doesn't
exist and we may have to figure out even
more sophisticated ways of
pushing a lot of data through um but we
don't really know yet
here's our smart meter um a lot of
people are scared of smart meters uh
they either use wi-fi or they use uh
915 megahertz unlicensed spectrums they
talk to these
it's a i guess it's a mesh network is it
smart meters
and so a bunch of different
units form a mesh network these talk to
one another and ultimately this
information is transmitted back
centrally so some questions um
the great infrastructural change of our
time
is moving from fixed infrastructures to
mobile but mobile really isn't mobile
because it takes massive and often
expensive fixed interest infrastructure
to enable
we can miniaturize infrastructure we can
make it smaller and we can build it into
the edges of the network you know the
whole
idea of the internet that it's smart at
the edges and it's dumb in the center
but you know quite often providers of
bandwidth or other
rivalrous goods and services don't want
to give up control
you know we have the same issue with uh
home-based solar systems which in many
states
you can't plug into the grid um so that
when the power goes off you go off
because they don't want you to pump a
lot of electricity and endanger
utility workers not every cell phone
scriber is allowed to tether
use their phone as a modem spectrum is
highly regulated certain users are
subsidized
broadcast broadcasters pay for their
licenses but they have a lot more
spectrum it's cheaper
should we open up spectrum to equipment
that can jump all over the place
and use it more efficiently should we
have more unlicensed spectrum
the wi-fi boom was huge we could do it
again but some people
um are going to find their holdings
demonetized
there's a steady move towards
deregulation but it isn't inevitable
there's an uncertain situation regarding
privacy
um we used to have party line phones we
used to have telegrams we used to have
postcards
pretty transparent now we have encrypted
gsm
phones so we can hear each other but
government agencies and a lot of
corporations
can hear us or they can look at our
metadata this is festering
it's unresolved so few trajectories um
a movement from radio links that move
from the center to the periphery
to virtual and mediated links like trunk
systems are like telephones where
there isn't a a fixed telephone line
between me and you
we use a phone line as long as we need
one same way with
with trunk systems we see mesh networks
that are pretty autonomous
we see a lot of silos we see systems
that don't interoperate
with one another there's the old
hardware based radios that you have to
tune to a specific frequency
or software radios which can jump all
over the place we'll talk a little bit
more about them
systems get more complex a lot of
communications infrastructure there was
a huge
covert communications infrastructure in
the cold war that mostly we know about
now
we're beginning to re to replicate a
sort of dark world of covert
infrastructure on a really major level
and then there's these networks that can
monitor movement and behavior
and this isn't just you know evil
government agencies it's
it's um it's uh it's when you walk into
a uh a clothing store and um
certain and you know they do the
bluetooth beacon thing
to either collect or to send information
to your phone do we have a right to know
do we have a right to peer
into them we might call for a certain
kind of disclosure
but you know fundamentally we don't even
know anymore what agencies are out there
this is a really really interesting
question um
in the 80s i did research for i did a
two-way radio guide for new york city
when i lived there and i found that
there were
32 types of city
county and state police in new york
and then i didn't even try to do the
feds and now i would imagine there's
probably double that
and i think that some of these agencies
don't even have names or their private
contract um what networks don't we know
about
there's video feeds they're often
aggregated places there's um we've been
reading lately about aerial
observation the fbi planes this isn't so
secret it's very easy to
to figure that kind of stuff out mobile
observation platforms the automatic
license plate readers
face and gate recognition apparently
your gate
is much more of you know a unique
identifier than your face
we haven't read very much about that yet
i'm really interested in the internet of
things you know when everything's
is tagged and um and either their active
tags or their passive tags that are
pulled all over the place
we're suddenly going to see billions and
billions and billions of new
emitters and what does that information
mean when you aggregate it it's a
fascinating and to me still
rather murky uh radio landscape and then
obviously cell phone metadata
observation
if you look uh as you um as you uh
travel along the highways you can see
antennas that look at
at your um what we call fast track here
to see where you're going and there's a
lot of people who look at um
cell phone metadata just to track
aggregate
movement of people that's how google can
correct its
its maps and you know when the highway
clears up ahead suddenly it isn't red on
your phone anymore
and the latency is down to just a matter
of seconds
one point i'd like to kind of um i'm
moving towards a
a close here but one of the points i
really like to stress is that we've got
a really stable
communications infrastructure but it's
also fragile and i'm really curious
about why
we have this existing landline phone
infrastructure
that's extremely robust it's been in in
service for a long long time
but people don't want it and they're
giving it up in the name of portability
and they're neglecting the very well
engineered but boring
telephone infrastructure for exciting
terminals you know like my beautiful
android phone and we're trading
portability and convenience
for um resiliency you know this phone
might be good for a couple hours in a
disaster
because there isn't going to be a lot of
battery backup at cell sites and of
course the system is going to be
overloaded
landlines and pagers work well broadcast
radio worked really well
um but we we have all these new
platforms but they're really fragile
and they're more expensive um and
there's data bloat
so i'm really curious how that's going
to happen we're a little worried about
the
security and the independence of
commercial services
one might i think certain people might
be interested in
the rebirth of messengers and couriers
and steganography
drones that deliver to well you can
shoot a drone down but to
verifiable addresses
i'll go past that so this is the um
the san francisco emergency siren system
uh you've all heard it go off on tuesday
at
noon when they do the tests and this is
the map of the current sirens
and um take a look just by the way at
the great highway in
taraval i believe it's number is it 75
or 78
and it's gray which means um it's out of
service and in a moment i'm going to
show you why and here today i had the
great privilege of being with a man
when he actually activated them for the
noon tuesday test that's the mouse click
that
that did it on tuesday
you know doesn't take much to excite a
geek
um but they told me
um that they'd pulled the side the um
the speakers or the the the speakers and
sirens at paravalent great highway out
of service and here's why
because there's a a red-tailed hawk
nesting there
so megan and i went down and took a
photograph of it this afternoon and it's
kind of life affirming but the question
is they don't know when they can turn it
back
on because the um the hawks will fledge
but the question is will other birds
move in or will the hawks come back it's
quite an issue
um
i'd love to see um again i don't really
want to go into this but one of the
things we need in san francisco
is hyper local news and information
radio
with um nothing but what's happening in
san francisco i think it would be quite
useful
the problem with running over-the-air
radio of course is your electric bill
and the cost of a license um
community wireless networks you know i
haven't talked there's people here who
can talk about
efforts that are being made right now
but here's a proposal from the 1960s
from the
cauliflower newsletter which was the
intercommunal newsletter of hippie
communes and somebody suggested that um
communes this is what about 1969 or 68
somebody suggested that um they link up
a net of cb
and business ban they got a little
confused so they could speak all the way
from
canada to mexico um so
just to very end very quickly we need to
have a field guide to invisible
infrastructure in san francisco here's
some of the indicators
that we might track some of the ways
that we might use it some of the tools
i wish somebody would do it here
somebody took a first stab in new york
ingrid burnington made this book
um called networks of new york but i
think we should really do it here and
there's some
a groundswell behind that and it'd be a
neat project
anyway i'd like to thank you all for
your attention and we have time i think
for a few
q's and a's
[Applause]
rick i like to think that you got to
press the alarm system because you were
the 20th caller on the radio station but
assume that's probably not the case i
just i
i watched it so uh you you mentioned you
lived in new york for for many years
do you have a sense i know you haven't
done the same kind of research there
how new york or other cities
is are there factors that are unique to
how things sort of evolved here
different technologies that caught on
faster or or or deeper
with the community or stuck around
longer when
it's really hard to do things in new
york you know the density is incredible
the cost of doing things is very high
new york is much more tribal
information isn't shared i would have
never been able to
have the tour that i had today in new
york city because people are much more
paranoid and closed
um i
it's one of the reasons we're lucky to
live in san francisco
it's still not the most open process
and you know we have a lot of commercial
providers who don't
talk to anybody for business reasons but
um we have some challenges here because
of the hills and because of the
of density but i think um you can't
really compare
we just don't have that same level of
crunch
uh who's got a question out there right
there that's you
hey so that was great are you working on
part two
i'd love to work on part two i don't
think i'm the best person to work on
part two you know i've looked at the
fiber maps and i've been to a lot of
you know i've been to peering and colo
facilities but i
have a lot to learn about that i think
there's other people that will probably
do it better
and i forgot to mention you know rick's
going to be sticking around so please
stick around and we'll keep the
conversation going
we'll only have a couple more questions
and maybe rick you can entice some of
these mysterious people that are in the
room that know
uh more about some of the infrastructure
to join into a larger conversation
well this is ongoing and it'll get
better over time great
um back right back there
so the question is the the networks that
were put in in the 90s
uh phone net phone data fiber operatic
networks
do you know has has that been tracked as
people know what's out there even
i mean there's you know keeping track of
those as a business and
people have to know where fiber is
buried so that they won't cut it when
they dig
a lot of times they don't call 8-1-1 to
do that but
i do think that knowledge is there it
isn't on the open internet for the most
part
because it's for a bunch of reasons
companies don't want to
fiber is very easy to cut and i don't
think they want
you know joe public doing that because
he's angry
uh alexander rose our executive director
you mentioned the
kind of underestimation of the early
phone networks
and i remember seeing at global business
network
one of the few people who predicted the
demise of the soviet
system was actually the person who
tracked penetration of phone networks
in oppressive
government systems and actually he said
at a certain point of
phone penetration that's when these
systems will go down you predicted when
the soviet system would go down
and so we've seen kind of echoes of that
now in
the internet with penetration of things
like twitter and facebook
in the arab spring i wonder have you
tracked any of those kind of parallels
well you know um since i became a
professor recently there's kind of an
imperative to try to take a position on
these kinds of issues
and all i can say right now is that you
know when you talk about the arab spring
or you talk about turkey or you talk
about um
ferguson that there's a correlation
between
communication channels and messaging but
i'm not sure there's a causation
and the thing is that the internet you
know to exist the internet and all the
services built on top of it
require a steady source of power
reasonably compliant uh states
um that let it keep going and
also you know citizen access and so i
don't think that the causation is really
established i do think there's a
correlation between being able to to
communicate it's a human right
and um you know that that long arc of
democracy but i'm not sure that the long
arc of democracy
is super democratic right now it's a
different kind of
it's something it's a fusion that's um
you know we confuse
uh openness and authoritarianism quite
well now
um so i i don't have a strong opinion
yet
all right last question from the bar
um we talked a little bit about
bay area in terms of
radio networks wi-fi networks healing
networks
in my experience in 2001 during the
terrorist attacks of 9 11
um one of the things that i contributed
to personally
was allowing people to come at columbia
university and anyone walking by
to have free voice over ip access to
international
phone calls and one of the things that
i'm interested in and i'd love to have
your opinion
is if our phone number ever went down
here in san francisco what kind of
network accessibility do you think would
be most important
here in san francisco could i toss this
question to mike mccarthy
do you want to do you want to talk do
you feel like just explaining that
possibility for a minute or two
here you go yeah so you should tell who
mike
is i'm mike um
so everyone uh so i work for the city's
uh department of technology and i've
known rick for a little while i've
definitely appreciated his shows at the
castro every christmas um
and to your point um i build uh
community wi-fi networks along with uh
tim pozar
um ronaldo flawless with tim um and we
also have build up public wi-fi as sort
of a city department
but tim and i have sort of our own
little uh
[Music]
tim and mike network that uh provides uh
tim and mike's excellent network there
you go
buy the rights now um that uh
provides free wi-fi internet at about 70
80 sites around the city and we use
unique strands of city fiber
that all go back to a building called
200 paul tuner paul is a commercial data
center at paul and third out in the
bayview
used to be an old sears warehouse and
macy's clearly tim knows more uh macy's
site that's pretty much
whenever you click on the internet on a
network on your phone or device
your packets go through that building
most likely so
we have a what's called a cross connect
out to the public internet via brewster
at the internet archive
internet brewster and ralph donate a one
gig pipe to the public internet
so to your your point um
there are we haven't really thought that
far out but there are possibilities to
build a
sort of secondary network off that as
long as the sites that are connected via
fiber
all have electricity the light can
travel through those devices
and get two tuner pawl assuming tuner
paul's up and running
um but i think if you have i think rick
sort of alluded to this but if you
really want to get more
deep details about the internet and how
it works
tim clearly knows a whole lot tim has a
very interesting project called sf mix
sf mix is a non-profit peering fabric
and
peering is basically making sure your
packets of data
don't leave the building to go to
netflix but they go
through another cabinet that have a
connection between the two sites
so peering is i think a really
interesting you know next step
of this um anyway i'm glad to talk more
about this
um at the break thanks
thank thank you mike rick that is the
first lifeline i've ever had a speaker
that's fantastic um thank you so much uh
so
the evening is going to continue um rick
i would like to give you uh one of our
long now
challenge coins to thank you for
speaking tonight
[Music]